starting off this hour is will in New
Hampshire
I will how are you hi Dave how are you
thank you for taking my call today my
pleasure sir
how can I help David need your help
salia I could say I'm over $500,000 in
debt I don't know what to start I been
listening to you for about a few weeks I
just don't know what to tacko I don't
know exactly where would it go from here
my wife and I pretty much I just don't
know exactly with the star I'm sorry you
found it and I'm sure you are
overwhelmed what kind of debt is the
five hundred thousand I got a rental
property that I own about two hundred
and twelve thousand dollars
currently I got my own house which I
live on we owe about $180,000 my wife
has a car and I know you're gonna scream
on this one forty forty one thousand
dollar loan that car that we bought
I got a fifty five thousand dollar
credit cards and the final we have our I
took along from my 401k for $25,000
mm-hmm and what do you make a year sir
household income
well between her and I we made about a
hundred and ten thousand a year that's
good news okay oh yeah but I don't even
know where he's going
I hear you okay well the good news is
you got your wake-up call and my dad
used to say when I was growing up he
would send me down to clean up the
basement and I'd say are you gonna help
and he would say no I recognized the
problem you're gonna go do it
recognizing the problem is half the work
he used to say so you recognize there's
a problem and so now we got some we got
something we can work with here so is
the rental property what does it make
money uh yeah it makes about a what a
hundred bucks every month but that when
it comes to water because we have to pay
water anyway so basically it just breaks
even yeah and if something big breaks it
loses money pretty much yes
it's probably a bigger problem than it
is an asset so won't we go ahead and
sell it ok so what's it worth right now
but oh I last time I checked because the
tax is going up so we're looking about
out to $70,000 maybe okay so when we
sell it we could throw a whole bunch of
the money at your credit card debt your
car your 401k loan that kind of stuff
right cuz you're gonna make some money
on it when you sell it you make 40 you
make 40 50 grand on it right Ned of
everything it sounds like yeah well we
after paying the rear staying all that
yeah I mean you got 75 or 80 thousand
dollars and equity plus or minus some
expenses and so you're gonna make some
money on it and we'll throw that at
those debts so that's gonna help that's
good news okay you got a good income
your house is not too big it's not out
of control you're right the car is
pretty much in stupid land what's the
other car worth well that's the only car
we have a one car we all know no okay
what's the other caller worth Oh with a
mysterious man I don't I think we we're
not even breaking even with that thing
because last time I checked no I
necessarily asked what the value of your
other vehicle is the one that I all the
money no sure the other one the other
ones I don't know I don't even know I
got a pilot so I would think about my
seller would be $4,000 $5,000 I think I
got a whole duck or I could probably
sell it for two thousand three thousand
dollars I would say the most okay so
other cars aren't worth nearly as much
is this one big dumb one right no cuz
the other ones I don't have to pay any
anybody well I don't mean that but I
mean the value if you sold it
that thing would bring like thirty
thousand your other cars are like five
thousand dollar cars so now so is there
three drivers in your house yeah
currently yeah my wife my sell my
daughter okay
dang gotcha okay alright so here's the
rule of thumb on cars if the total of
all your vehicles in value added
together equals MA
more than half your annual income you
have too much tied up in car and you're
probably right on the bubble on that
you're probably a little under half but
up high enough that this car does look
like it's crazy land so you can keep it
if you want to keep it but you're gonna
have to plow through this stuff so we
sell the rental and we get you on a
tight budget beans and rice rice and
beans know life you're not gonna go on
vacation you're not gonna see the inside
of a restaurant unless you're working
there we're getting out of debt because
life is too rough living in New Jersey
making 110,000 dollars being this
freakin broke so you're gonna get with
it it's game on okay okay and lean in
and sell the rental throw at it you're
gonna list these other debts the credit
cards and the car and the 401k smallest
to largest I suspect the smallest debts
are credit cards because there's
probably several in that fifty five
thousand and so you're going to plow
through those with the proceeds of the
sale of the rental house you're gonna
plow through those with the proceeds of
your newly formed very very very very
very very tight budget where you have no
life all you're doing is getting out of
debt so you get your life back because
if you didn't have any payments but your
house payment you be in dreamland
wouldn't you sir yes I would it's just
it's disorganized exactly you can do
this so jump on every dollar I'm gonna
put you and your wife through Financial
Peace University I'm gonna give you the
one-year membership do what wow that's
great I'll give you the one-year
membership and that includes the nine
week class and includes connectivity to
the bank on your every dollar plus with
your budget and you and your wife both
have to go to the class because if one
of you goes out the other one you kill
them you know create a big fight okay
because all of a sudden one of you I
have knowledge the other one doesn't
have it it will be fun at your house
yeah you mix in a little marital
disagreement with some financial stress
we got real gumbo going here so we don't
need that you gonna you gonna do this if
I give it to you yes sir of course is my
guy so I want to talk to you again if
you're struggling if you're hurt and
then you don't know what to do I'm here
for you or at a minimum I want to talk
to you when you do your debt free scream
okay yes sir